so good afternoon everybody welcome to
the Yale Law School
torian's to Yale University it's a
distinct honor today my name is Peter
Sullivan president of Yale and it's a
distinct honor to introduce our 2015
chub fellow President Obama's national
security adviser Susan Rice ambassador
rice we welcome you to Yale University
and we're so grateful for your
willingness to share your time and
insights with all of us we're delighted
that ambassador rice is joined today by
a member of her family who is also a
member of our family this is John rice
Yale College class of 1988 and a current
fellow of the Yale corporation before I
speak about our visitors I want to say a
few words about the history of the Chubb
fellowship so Hendon Chubb was in the
1895 graduate of yells Sheffield
scientific school that's the precursor
to the Yale School of Engineering and
Applied Sciences in 1936 he made a
substantial gift to Yale University to
encourage students to take an interest
in public service since 1949 the Chubb
endowment has been used to underwrite
prestigious visiting speakers who would
bring kind of an extra extraordinary
presences to campus that would inspire
our students this Fellowship is
administered by the master of timothy
dwight college Marylou past Chubb
fellows have included four presidents of
the United States presidents of eight
other countries and more than 150 other
regional national and internationally
prominent individuals noted for their
distinction in service to the common
good the annual Chubb lecture is a
wonderful opportunity to reinforce the
shared values of our community and I
know it's a special treat today for you
well to hear from someone who is serving
at the very heart of our nation and our
national interest as National Security
Advisor ambassador rice oversees the
National Security Council staff chairs
the national security principles
committee provides the president's daily
national security briefing and it's
responsible for coordinating the
administration's foreign policy
intelligence and military efforts she
has held numerous appointments within
the National Security Council including
his director for international
organizations and peacekeeping as
special assistant to President Clinton
and as Senior Director for African
affairs from 1997 to 2001 she was the
u.s. Assistant Secretary of State for
African affairs and in 2000 she was Co
recipient of the White House's Samuel
Nelson drew memorial award for
distinguished contributions to the
formation of peaceful cooperative
relationships between States as a senior
advisor for national security affairs in
the with the Obama for America campaign
she went on to serve as a member of the
advisory board for the obama-biden
transition and then as co-chair of its
policy working group on national
security from 2002 to 2009 she was a
senior fellow at the Brookings
Institution where she focused on u.s.
foreign policy transnational security
threats weak States global poverty and
development before her appointment as
national security advisor in 2013 she
served as the u.s. permanent
representative to the United Nations
where she worked to strengthen national
and global security and to promote human
rights ambassador Rice received her BA
in history from Stanford University she
holds an MPhil and D fill in
international relations from new college
at Oxford University and she was a
Rhodes Scholar there this is a
remarkable opportunity for our students
not just to learn about issues in
national security but to learn about a
career path in public service that I am
sure is an inspiration I'm particularly
pleased that today's lecture will
actually take the form of a conversation
and it's a conversation between
ambassador rice and as I hinted at
earlier a member of the elk community
who is uniquely positioned to join her
here on stage why do I say that well
John rice Yale College a TA and fellow
and bl Corporation is the founder and
CEO of management leadership for
tomorrow which is a nonprofit
organization that helps members of
underrepresented minority groups to
become leaders in the corporate
nonprofit and entrepreneurial sectors
after graduating from Yale with a degree
in Latin American Studies he earned his
MBA from the Harvard Business School and
while at Harvard he wrote a business
plan for his current organization and in
1994 he launched it and launched it via
a mentoring program for minority
undergraduates he was appointed to
President Obama's Advisory Commission on
educational excellence for
african-americans and has served as a
member of the president's Board of
Advisors on historically black colleges
and universities he also serves on a
number of nonprofit boards including
list the National Center for civil and
human rights the American Management
Association the Woodrow Wilson national
fellowship foundation as I mentioned he
is a member of the Yale Corporation the
trustees of Yale University are
fiduciaries before that he was a member
of the University Council it's the visor
II group to the president but most
importantly for today's purposes he
holds a very special role and that is he
is ambassador Rice's brother younger
brother so
so I would like you to join me in
thanking him for facilitating today's
conversation and to also join me in
extending a very long warm welcome to
Connecticut to New Haven to Yale
University to Ambassador Susan Rice
I feel like I need a phone book can you
all see me Johnny get all the height in
the family yeah she says that she'd like
to say that I'm a younger brother
because she feels that she looks younger
that's exactly the side pseudos so
thanks for having us first of all and I
think we're going to try to have some
fun over the course of of the of the
hour here and as Peter said approach
this a little bit differently than
potentially some of the past chub-chub
fellow lectures but what we'd like to do
and we again I'll say you know Susan and
I have had plenty of fireside chat over
the years but none in public so this is
the first time we've done this and bear
with us right so who knows where it will
go but we hope it will be instructive
and I think we'd like to structure it in
a way that was a little bit different
than if this were a you know if I were
someone like a real interviewer okay
someone who does this for a living
who happens you know and because I'm her
brother hopefully we can we can push a
little bit further on some issues if
she'll let me get a little bit more
personal and and hopefully we'll keep it
professional and hopefully we'll still
like each other when we're done right so
so we'll sway it the way we're going to
structure this in terms of the fireside
chat before we open it up for questions
from you all is we'll talk a little bit
about the core here you know sort of
foreign policy which is you know you're
living and breathing every day and then
I think we'd like to broaden it and talk
more generally about issues that I think
that I know that Susan cares about that
cut across they may they may incorporate
foreign policy but they may be focused
on other issues and and that she thinks
are important you want to hear her
thoughts and those two themes there and
then we want to give you more personal
and and give you all a sense of what
makes her tick and hopefully to share
some advice and perspective from the of
the experiences that she's had so that's
going to be the approach obviously we'll
open up for questions and we can go
anywhere with those questions as well so
okay so no no
well it is what it is got for some water
there too for this is something she
never done she's never you know pouring
some water for me that's actually not
true she's a great cook and and she has
over for dinner on Sunday night and did
a fantastic job so appreciate that so
let's start foreign policy and we know
that she had a high-pressure job and to
say the least one of the highest
pressure pressure cooker jobs I think in
the world and so my first question
really is you know when described a time
where you have been the most nervous all
right when we worried the most about
having to go do something before you did
this is going to sound strange to some
of you but the work I do every day in my
job is work that I feel relatively
comfortable with and I've been doing it
for the better part of my career and I'm
a stress about issues or stress about
how a particular event would trip or
visit may come out but that's very
normal manageable stress for me the most
stressed I've ever been in life in all
honesty was when I had to throw out the
opening pitch at the Nationals game in
2013 I had just taken my job as national
security adviser that month I am a
decent athlete but I'm at no particular
skill at baseball and I was determined
to throw it from the mound and at least
wanted to get it across in the vicinity
of the plate to the plate at least the
distance and I was practicing for weeks
really and
I was lucky enough that some of the guys
on my security detail were willing to
throw with me so we'd go out we throw a
few on a Saturday or Sunday and the
transition occurred right as I left my
job at the UN and was coming over to the
White House and my security detail
switched from Diplomatic Security that
helped me and took care of me when I was
a UN Ambassador to Secret Service and
the my lead agent on Secret Service was
determined that I was not going to
humiliate everybody at the plate and so
he was kind enough to throw with me in
the tunnel right before I went out on
the field and I had to go out and I was
struck by how fast it all happened you
get there and they say okay go to the
mound and you 50,000 people are watching
you and you're either going to get it or
you're not going to get it and you can
imagine that you know I've been the
subject of a little bit of public
criticism on occasion and I could just
see Fox News you know doing a loop
on me grounding the ball you know so I
got up there and there was no time and
they said okay Susan Rice the National
Security Advisor Johnny was there and
was mostly cheers there are some audible
boos and I just had to throw and I wound
up and threw it and I threw a strike
across the plate and my heart rate went
from probably 190 back down to something
like 70 and rotor Fawcett said well
mother's a dirty rag Don me until you
know there was no end and he had done
the same and of course manager threw a
pitch so he would have talked about me
and then I was worried frankly on behalf
of all women kind that you know if I let
the side down that it would have been
terrible so that was stress of a sort I
was not accustomed to and I'm never ever
doing it again not the answer that's
been tested so so let's talk about a
Syria let's switch isn't if it'll all be
here all right well that stresses me out
too right
so I know you share with me like how you
know this is maybe the most complicated
foreign policy issue that you that
you've had to deal with it'll actually
in your career in part because you know
it seems like they're you know almost
nothing but bad options that cascade
into another set of worst options and
even worse scenarios and so forth so you
know first question so is there is there
any path to a political solution and is
there any way that we can mitigate or
alleviate this humanitarian crisis
that's coming out of there well honestly
I do I do think that the crisis in Syria
is the hardest problem to solve that
I've encountered and I've felt that way
from the very beginning four and a half
years ago and it's only getting harder
there's no question I do think there is
a path to a political solution and we're
working very hard towards that as we
have for quite a while but as the
dynamics have changed and the
circumstances have evolved
in some ways the path is more fraught
when you consider that this is now a
multi-front conflict it's the opposition
against Assad Assad against the
opposition and his people
it's itsel and al-nusra the al-qaeda
affiliate
against both of those sides and it's the
world against disel and al-nusra so it
is a mash-up if there is such a thing on
the battlefield and the only way this
gets resolved is through a political
solution there's no other way I mean you
could have local ceasefires conceivably
we have periodic success in humanitarian
access but to deal with the primary
concern we have which is defeating ISIL
and ensuring that the threat that that
very pernicious terrorist organization
poses is not exacerbated and doesn't
reach our shores is our primary focus
but to accomplish that obviously we also
have to deal with the fundamental
underlying conflict which is a civil
conflict which has taken an
extraordinary humanitarian toll and we
obviously have a great interest in
alleviating the suffering and that war
can only end at the negotiating table
that's going to require a resolution not
frankly dissimilar from what was
envisioned back in Geneva in 2012 when
we were part of a negotiation that
established a framework that envisioned
a transitional governing authority
agreed by mutual consent between the
opposition and the government in the
theory of that was if there had to be
mutual consent there couldn't be the
perpetuation of the assad façades
leadership in a regime that had lost all
legitimacy with its people there would
have to be other elements from the
existing government that had less blood
on its hands in practice elements of the
opposition who were capable of bringing
expertise to a transitional governing
body and then a period of transition
time to be determined during which a new
constitute
could be written elections could be
organized a ceasefire implemented etc
that still remains fundamentally the the
likeliest outcome when eventually we get
to a political solution we are trying
very hard to accelerate the achievement
of the political solution and secretary
Kerry last week met in Vienna with the
foreign ministers of Turkey and Saudi
Arabia and Russia who are key players
obviously in this and he will meet again
in what I expect will be just several
days time with that group and then a
broader group of countries in the region
with the aim of trying to operationalize
some kind of political transition in
ceasefire the big thorny issue that
remains is when and whether Assad steps
aside our view remains that he has to go
that there can't be an end to this
conflict which has taken so many lives
and cost cause so much suffering and you
know displacement of over four million
people without him departing as part of
the transition but at what stage of the
transition is something that is being
discussed and debated we have very
different views and our coalition
partners do from the Syrian government
the Russians and the Iranians
but I think there is the potential for
an arrangement to be agreed where in
this transition begins perhaps with
Assad still in power but that it doesn't
end with him in power and went along
that continuum the transition and his
removal occurs is is the hardest issue
the other challenge is frankly that the
opposition is extraordinarily fragmented
and there is no single group or leaders
that speaks for those that have been
fighting Assad and now the opposition
there is what we believe to be or call
and work with the moderate opposition
but they are sometimes commingled with
the extremist opposition including
elements like al-nusrah or those
affiliated with al misra the only thing
that most people and I would say almost
everybody agrees with is that it so is a
problem that can only be dealt with
directly and confrontationally and so
the aim is to get this political
solution as soon as possible and turn
our collective efforts without the
distraction of these ongoing civil
conflict against disel right and we
haven't talked about Iraq but obviously
that's very much part of the same hole
right so so it's incredibly complicated
and I've been and if if we so for close
of us who are not in there with you and
the president and secretary Kerry and
you're in your team's thinking through
these issues you know you know I'm
always I've always been curious sort of
you know what principles human
principles you kind of pull from and
whether czar you know beyond the issues
here is there anything that that those
of us who are not in your world can
glean about sort of what principles to
draw upon when you're dealing with a
situation where there are no good
options and you have to decide among
things among options that are you know
just that where you don't have a
positive set of options and I'm
wondering you know is there is anything
that we can learn from think again
outside of foreign policy in our own
lives any thought you'd have on what
principles that you know what you've
learned what principles we can draw upon
that are relevant to to our lives
outside of your world I'm not sure if
the lessons are directly applicable and
then in the world of foreign policy and
national security at the risk of
oversimplifying you know the first
question or the first principle that we
have to wrestle with is quite frankly
what is in the United States national
interest but and that may be different
the answer to that question very
ruthlessly defined maybe not as edifying
as we might want to believe I mean it is
it in the United States national
interest for example in Syria too
it deeply involved in the conflict on
the ground in a combat role well we've
seen the consequences of the conflict
continuing that's a they are deeply
insidious consequences that are have
horrific outcomes for the people of
Syria are destabilizing given the
refugee outflow to the neighbors are now
having implications with the refugee
flow for Europe and now we have the
challenge of Issel which does directly
threaten our interests and that of our
allies and partners but we may have to
tailor our our solutions to more
narrowly to the challenge of defeating
ISIL than to the broader challenges that
are important that we care about but are
not the ones we must prioritize so at
the same time we can we can alleviate
humanitarian suffering we are the
largest contributor to the humanitarian
response with over 4.5 billion dollars
but you know as human beings we all want
to to do what is you know the right
thing on a human level and sometimes
some time off Tintin what is right on a
human level is also what most or best
serves US interests but it's not a
hundred percent coincidence and
sometimes the hardest choices are when
those things can't be readily reconciled
so now translating that into you know
daily life is hard I mean when you face
circumstances where in your personal or
professional life you have no good
answers and no good options you know I
think I don't know that I can say you
know take this lesson from the Situation
Room and apply it somewhere else but I
think one thing I'd say is you know when
you examine your options you have to ask
not only what will be the effect of a
particular action but you also have to
ask what will be the effective inaction
and way those and and try to anticipate
the consequences of your actions you
know three or four steps down the road
because what may be the most immediate
least bad answer today could prove to be
worse down the road and I suppose vice
versa so in trying to play out almost as
if a chess game the actions and
reactions is I guess the the best
analogy I can draw no Telkom but it's
it's it's hard to it's hard to make a
direct connection
I think that's instructive and so
stepping back a little bit I mean you've
been on you've been a core member of the
president foreign policy team from the
beginning right you started up at the UN
and now down the White House and I
assume you're going to stay till the end
okay I haven't heard otherwise
and so I want to ask you to if you kind
of reflect back you guys a lot has been
accomplished you know what are you most
proud of you think about a couple you
know want to mention a few milestones or
a few accomplishments that you're most
proud of that you weren't sure you could
get done when you when when when you
join the team back actually on the
campaign and then when the president was
sworn in and what were you most proud of
today
well with the caveat that that which I'm
most proud of doesn't mean that I had a
direct hand in Bocca accomplishing all
of them and I think vitally important
from a national security point of view
was the success that our economic team
had early on in turning around the
economy because a huge source of our
international strength is the strength
of our economy domestically and whether
we're able to grow and produce wealth
and jobs and when President came into
office we were as you will recall the
the lowest point since the Great
Depression
and now after years we are back to a
place of of economic leadership in the
world and the rest of the world has
certainly made progress but you know
they're the economy's in various
different parts of the world are still
relatively soft we are now not
impervious obviously but the strongest
link and that has been fundamental in
restoring our leadership abroad and but
beyond that obviously I mean we've tried
to focus on a number of things first of
all despite the the challenges that
still remain in Afghanistan and Iraq
when President Obama came into office we
had 180,000 troops and Middle's theaters
we are down to less than 10,000 in
Afghanistan today we'll be going down to
5,500 by the end of next year and we're
about 3,300 in Iraq and very narrowly
tailored missions to supporting the
Iraqis and the Afghans by training and
advising and assisting them we're not in
combat in either theater directly
anymore and we're also can engage in
counterterrorism in a targeted way I
think you know the fact that we've been
able to redeploy and rebalance and
refresh our our armed forces is vitally
important to our readiness in our
ongoing strength even as the nature of
challenges has evolved but I'm
particularly pleased that when you look
around the world we're rebalancing to
Asia and the Asia Pacific a great deal
of our time and energy that doesn't get
a lot of attention in the press is
devoted to the work that we're doing in
the Asia Pacific we have just had over
the last several months high profile and
very impactful visits from the Japanese
leader the Chinese leader the South
Korean leader just this week the
Indonesian leader we are heading to Asia
next month again we have gone if not
every year then twice every year in the
recent past for very important summit
meetings out there and we've just been
able to conclude the trans-pacific
partnership trade agreement which is a
signature element of the Asia rebalance
so I think that's something that will be
of lasting significance we've all worked
very hard on the issue of
non-proliferation and trying to reduce
the threat from loose what some people
call loose nukes which is not the term
we're supposed to use but you know we
have strengthened nuclear security in a
very meaningful way and then of course
we've been able to reach the agreement
to prevent Iran from obtaining a nuclear
weapon with the support of the
international community and I think that
will prove if fully implemented to have
been an unexpected and yet very
meaningful means of constraining a very
dangerous nuclear program and ensuring
that Iran is not able to obtain a
nuclear weapon so that that's another
thing I think frankly when we look back
on our time I certainly will be very
pleased that we've made an opening with
Cuba and that 50 years of failed policy
have been supplanted by what I think
will prove over the long term to be the
most effective means of opening up Cuba
both politically and economically and
finally and I could go on but you know
as a policy maker but also as a mother
and as a citizen I mean one of the
issues that that I'm most concerned
about and I know the president has put
the highest priority on is climate
change and trying to address that threat
and we are now heading into Paris in
December for the cop meeting on climate
change with the real potential of
achieving an agreement that will ratchet
down emissions in a meaningful way and
we've been able to negotiate with China
and unpurchased we're the first and the
second largest admit errs emitters of
greenhouse gases an unprecedented mutual
commitment
to reduce our carbon output and that has
set the stage for us to be able to gain
commitments from countries amounting to
eighty percent eighty five percent now
of emissions around the world to make
very concrete national commitments to
reduce their emissions so if we can get
this agreement in Paris and if it is
meaningful and substantive that will be
a huge step and steps we've taken
domestically to reinforce that are a
critical part as well got it so if I
could pivot a little bit just to an area
that you don't get to talk too much I at
least so much about publicly and I think
you know but I know you well enough to
know that you are passionate about some
things that go beyond foreign policy
right and there are things that are
important to our nation and one of the
things that you share with me Susan you
know is your passion for sort of
improving equality of opportunity in
this nation and globally and and so when
you think about hot-button issues that
that are like like criminal justice
reform and policing and immigration
health care k-12 education and gay
marriage I mean so many of them relate
to this you know are related to this the
issue of equality of opportunity and
some of these issues you all really move
the needle on it and within the context
of administration over the last seven
years
some are rising to the top now but I
just want to get your you know your
point of view not necessarily from the
point of view note perspective of the
administration okay because this is not
your lane I wish I would write get out
of mine but given that you know we're
here with members of the New Haven
community and students and professors
here at the University who are ambitious
and idealistic and are tackling some of
these tough issues you know in your mind
you know what are the one or two
critical levers that we should focus on
in our nation to move the needle on
equality of opportunity well then
okay how do we okay I'm sorry
so can you hear better now thank you for
saying it I wish you'd said thank you
thank you these are unusual contraptions
can you hear me
yeah okay sorry so repeat the question
so the question is when you think about
you know addressing equal you know
inequality here in equality of
opportunity in this nation and you can
speak global if you like you know if you
if you were folks in the crowd if you
know what should we what can we move the
needle on what are the things the levers
that we should be focusing on to to
build a nation that as a that really
addresses it moves the needle on on on
equality of opportunity well I mean
Johnny I don't you know I'm this is
something I care deeply about but it's
not an area that I'm expert into I I
think you heard from the introduction of
my background and Johnny's I call him
Johnny by the way he some people call
him John that we've taken very different
career paths but we grew up in the same
household with the same values in the
same parents and the same many of the
same I think
motivations and concerns and I think
this is a an area that is united us
John's work is is really about building
ladders for those who have not had
necessarily all of the the privilege and
opportunity that has been that we've
been blessed with and that that many are
blessed with so that they have the
mentorship and the preparation and the
training to go into high-powered
careers and opportunities in business or
management or the nonprofit world but
the theory of jobs nonprofit is that if
you catch a young person early on and
give him or her with all of their
inherent talent the opportunities the
mentorship the training the support to
succeed then the likelihood of their
success goes way up and my own personal
passion that is Jonny said is not the
focus of my work day to day but is
fundamentally an animating motivation is
I believe deeply as many of us do in the
fundamental Worth and equality of every
human being and I believe fundamentally
and this may be part of my experience as
an african-american woman that there is
so much more talent out there than ever
is able to rise to the surface and that
we have not only an obligation and an
interest in nurturing and cultivating
that talent but that as a matter of
national strength and even indeed as a
matter of national security to the
extent that we are not cultivating and
nurturing that talent wherever it may
reside we are we are diminished we are
not firing on all cylinders we're
competing with one hand tied behind our
back
and so I I believe passionately that we
can do better and we have to do better
and that I I think frankly boils down to
what you all would assume and that is
sort of obvious which is education and
starting at the earliest stages at
preschool in early early education
preschool and all the way up through
higher education being able to provide
young people with the the support that
they need and deserve that means that
education has to be affordable it has to
be of a decent quality it has to be safe
and it has to be available to kids where
they come from inner-city New Haven or
from you know the wealthiest suburbs
elsewhere and frankly we still have not
done in my judgment as a nation a
sufficient job of focusing on that
deficit and investing in the talent that
this nation has and we are one of the
most skilled diverse rich societies in
the world and when I look out
internationally and I think how do we
sustain American leadership through the
21st century and beyond how do we
maximize our inherent strengths and I
don't mean just our military strength or
even our economic strength but our
social and our intellectual strength and
our cultural strength it necessitates
that we take advantage of this
extraordinary fabric that that is our
talented and diverse society and if
we're not doing that adequately not only
we're leaving behind so many but I
really truly believe we are not doing
our we're not fulfilling our potential
as a global leader right right so get
even more personal okay so I'm again
personal yes okay well here we go real
person all right we'll get more so
you're a mom of two yeah right you have
a seventh grader and you have a son
seventh grade daughter MERIS son and
high schools actually accompanied you
here Jake and and your wife of 23 years
is that right how many years okay and
you spend a lot of time I mean I've been
so impressed by how you've been able to
spend so much time over the course of
last eight years caring for her father
you know our mom now you know and
finding her finding time to do that so
so this is not a question about
work-life balance because I know
that's not you know even a a you know
part of a vocabulary here but I wanted a
you know I wanted to see if you have any
you know guiding principles around that
you could share with the audience here
about how to stay above water and not
let the most important balls drop how do
you approach it how do you know how do
you knowing that it's not perfect
knowing that that you've got to make
tough trade-offs in your personal life
you've you know you've you've kept the
most important I can attest to that
personally I've been really I really
admire you how you figured out how to do
that and it comes with trade-offs but
any you know what advice would you have
for the folks here whether they're
undergrad grad students here or folks
who are not students here on how to keep
the most important balls from dropping
when you're well let me first of all I'm
not trying to blow smoke here but Johnny
has given me a lot of credit and the
fact is we've both we have had will
we've been blessed with two wonderful
parents our father passed away four and
a half years ago our mom is still alive
she I think would have enjoyed being
here today she's in Washington and her
health is fragile and we have together I
think done a pretty good job of trying
to support our parents and we've
succeeded because we've done it together
along with my husband and Johnny's wife
and our kids and the answer to your
question is because you know it's a this
is teamwork no one individual can can
manage you know the challenges of taking
care of kids taking care of family
taking care of self
it does require partners very well
that's it that's your vote very well
definitely man oh yeah I've been adieu
to extraordinarily blessed to have this
the most wonderful supportive and you
know talented husband you have you've
done very well yourself
and and unfortunately everybody likes
each other so we really we have been a
team but if I had some advice I'd say
the following first of all everybody is
different every circumstance is
different and I hate these conversations
where you know women debate whether they
lean in lean out you know you know tell
everybody how to handle their lives my
view on this is everybody it's like it's
different
everybody's circumstance is different
people need to stop telling each other
what to do and just support each other
and recognize that everybody's trying to
make the best choice as they can in
their particular circumstances and
there's no one-size-fits-all formula the
only thing I can say from my vantage
point that has been a valuable principle
for me is that family comes first and
even in a job like mine
family comes first because and your
dearest friends because when everything
else falls apart that's what you've got
left you've got the people you love and
the people who love you and if you ever
forget that
then I think you're missing something
fundamental and I just want to say I
mean I've been I've thought a lot about
this in my own life and I've just seen
it modeled in the most extraordinary way
when having had the privilege of working
very closely with Vice President Biden
who has just gone through extraordinary
loss and men and in the context of
working you know the second toughest job
in the world and he has been there for
his family his family has been there for
him he was there for Bo just as he was
there for Bo and hunter early in their
lives when they suffered extraordinary
loss and he is living proof that you can
and you must invest your utmost in the
family even as you take on the most
challenging responsibilities that you
might find whether in government of the
private sector the nonprofit world so
you know there have been times in my
professional life and for
a life where it's you know we've hit
very painful patches but what is made it
all sustainable and worthwhile is that
we've had each other and we've had our
extended family and the love and support
of our kids and I've sent other parents
and our spouses and I think you know
it's a simple truism but I think
sometimes in the rush and the press of
professional life and stress that can
sometimes be forgotten and it shouldn't
be alright so before we open it up for
questions I have one last one and it
builds upon what you said and and it
speaks to you know yeah you've had cut
you've had a quite a roller coaster ride
right over the course of the last few
years I mean you you know the great run
at the UN felt like you got a lot done
there
Benghazi came up and that got
politicized the whole Secretary of State
stuff and and now what you talked about
some things that you've really been
excited about over the course of your
tenure here and as a national security
adviser so there probably lots of people
here today whose parents are worrying
how they will handle adversity when it
comes up how do you know and handle
setbacks because so many folks here up
at Yale haven't had big setbacks yet and
these aren't they could be a new
frontier because we've had so much
success in your lives today and I'm
wondering if when advice would you have
for these folks about what you draw on
when you have setbacks when you have
adversity well you know when that comes
wouldn't were you drawn D drawn from
family you know do what you have what do
you look at what do you do even when
especially when times where you feel
like you know you may or may not have
done anything to bring that diversity on
yourself
and that's a tough question but it's a
personal question but in anything you
would share with the group about how to
how to deal with adversity when it comes
well I think the first answer is the
answer I already gave which is the
family and friends and the strength that
they provide but I think also the
strength has got to come from inside and
I was just speaking very very personally
I have for better or for worse
I've always known Who I am I've always
known what I believe I've always tried
to do what I do with the utmost
integrity and in intensity and I believe
that you know I know who I am and I also
know who I'm not and when I'm watching a
caricature or a critique of myself that
is painful and personalized I'm able to
I don't want to suggest that I don't
feel the I don't feel offended or I
don't feel hurt in some instances by it
but I'm also able to distinguish between
what I know about myself and who I know
myself to be and what is being said and
there to the extent that I'm able to
understand and maintain that distinction
I can keep a certain distance from it
what's harder and I'll tell you that you
know this but I'll just acknowledge it
here the hardest thing for me going
through the period you described in 2012
was not what it felt like for me the
hardest thing was what I saw it do to my
mom and to my daughter
who were in very different ways and
different I mean what was Maris was
fifth grade
no 11th all know she's 12 now so he was
g99 really hit her very very hard she
was old enough to be able to understand
that her mom is being vilified on the
television and hear the things that were
being said and sort of understand why it
was happening but not really understand
that it did what you see isn't
necessarily all that there is his story
and it was it really was briefly but
intensely destabilizing for her and then
my mom who's tough as nails but has a
addiction to cable news just couldn't
turn television off but also was driving
her absolutely insane and this after
she'd just come out of the hospital and
been through you know surgery and very
difficult recovery and all this stuff
and you know she just was beside herself
and it was the only time that I was
really I hate to say I was glad bed
wasn't alive because if a dad had been
alive he would have taken his shotgun up
to Capitol Hill and it would have been
all over right
grew up in South Carolina right right
but uh you know you just the other thing
I'd say is that you you keep working and
keep doing what you believe and in some
ways it was great to be at the UN at the
time where the issues that we were
working on and that my fellow
ambassadors cared about were far removed
from the noise in Washington it never it
was incredible to me that as you an
ambassador I would
have to go before the UN press corps
multiple times a week and make
statements or take questions and never
once at the UN got asked about Benghazi
because they didn't care it was they
they saw it as a manufactured political
story and they wanted to ask about the
issues on the on the UN Agenda come to
Washington it's a little bit different
ya got
okay let's open it up so yeah why don't
you come on up as you will be much more
capable moderator than I look so how we
want to run this she's running it first
I just want to make sure we give a large
round of applause to ambassador rice and
[Applause]
and I want to thank Johnny but encourage
him to keep his day job so I am the
moderator of this QA session and I may
need to moderate up here as well as I
see oh there was a friendly handshake
that just happened I am the master of
Timothy Dwight College I'm Mary Lou and
I it's a real pleasure for me to greet
all of you and certainly welcome our two
wonderful guests who shared with us
their remarks and they covered so much
ground than their fireside chat so I
think there's going to be numerous
opportunities to ask questions to follow
up I also want to take the time really
quickly to thank president Sall avait
for his introductory remarks thank you
for that so we are going to open up for
questions right now so please go ahead
and line up either two microphones right
here and just be in a very orderly
fashion and we'll alternate between the
two microphones I'm seeing two very
large lines forming and we will not be
able to get through all of the questions
I already apologizing to the people in
the back so I will just say once you ask
your question please step aside from the
microphone and let's let our wonderful
guests respond so let's start on the
side I live in Ukraine I've done so for
the past 25 years I'd like to ask you
your view on the situation you crying
with reference to two things in
particular first to the violations of
Budapest treaty fundamentally undermine
nuclear non-proliferation for the future
and SEC can US with Japan which I
believe would be favorable to this I
know it would be and EU help to get the
world- mega political risk insurance
program going for Ukraine again so that
there can be an investment from the rest
of the world you've done a fine job with
OPEC but a lot of the world that was
invest in Ukraine has stopped and it's
produced a catastrophic 25 percent
decline in the GDP
and this wasn't caused by Ukraine it was
caused by Ukraine's reliance on the
security assurances of the Budapest
treaty based on which he gave up five
thousand nuclear weapons so can can the
United States help with us well
certainly we can and we are working to
help Ukraine put in many different ways
with its economic recovery
just yesterday just yesterday I was
saying we are we are working to help
Ukraine in various ways including with
its economic recovery just yesterday in
Kiev we announced the third one billion
dollar US government loan guarantee for
the government in Kiev we are providing
technical assistance for providing
military aid we're providing various
forms of security and economic support
to the government and the loan
guarantees of course are not the sum
total of our economic assistance but
they're a part and parcel we've also
been very active with Europe and the
international financial institutions to
try to provide the support that Ukraine
is now receiving through the
international financial institutions so
we are very much trying to support
economic recovery in Ukraine and and its
independence from its its former
dependence on on Russia and the East so
there is there is there been some
creative ideas and you may be referring
to some of the ideas that George Soros
has talked about correct and these are
ones that we have looked at very
carefully I have spoken myself to mr.
Soros about this as many of my
colleagues including secretary Lew his
idea relies on a mechanism within the
European Union and their ability to
activate a mechanism that could leverage
additional
and unfortunately there are a number of
complexities with it but the principle
one being that the Europeans have not
been interested in pursuing that obvious
his way of doing it is not the only way
there are other ways and was a lawyer in
the private sector there for 25 years we
have a lot of Pines that would like to
come in and make a contribution to the
economy private sector has been
forgotten he is correct without
political risk insurance when it gets to
board approval level companies are
afraid with that they will go forward
with the plans they would like to
implement and I personally have actually
my law firm a couple of billion dollars
of investment that is presently frozen
that could be unblocked with political
risk insurance at the mEagle level as
has been done for the West Bank in Gaza
that would work
sources mechanism probably doesn't well
I appreciate that and I'll look into it
thank you thank you yes this gentleman
here thank you ambassador rice and
brother you can call him Johnny
[Laughter]
it was very interesting you hear the
personal side and know that behind that
that very informal government figure
that you are that there is a very
personal side that's very important
I just want to my question has to do
with Syria but very quickly regarding
this gentleman Ukraine we represent a
consortium of students all over the
world and many of them are in Ukraine
and they asked me to ask you one
question or to let you know one thing
and that they are very concerned about
the fact that the general prosecutor in
Ukraine they feel is corrupt and is not
really doing making any progress in
terms of judicial reform in terms of
really reforming the judiciary and
reforming and getting rid of a lot of
government figures and this is what they
feel and they're just wondering if the
United States could exert some kind of
leverage or at least look into the fact
that this general prosecutor is is very
much not on the saw
of Ukraine citizenry but that my main
question has to do with Syria and what I
consider is a not a no-fly zone but a
buffer zone and the fact that we also
deal with Russian students and they all
seem to feel that the Russian government
might be very amenable to considering
the establishment of a buffer zones so
that refugees instead of having to cross
the Mediterranean could could rest or be
settled in this zone with obviously
there's a lot of you know there's a lot
of problems with that I realize there's
there's cost and then there's
possibility of conflict but if the
Russian government is willing to support
this and they feel it will because the
refugees a lot of these refugees or a
lot of these terrorists could a lot of
jihadists could be part of the refugees
and going back to Russia so that I'm
wondering why the United States
government has not pursued or at least
outwardly pursued the establishment more
of a buffer zone in Syria thank you very
much well thank you for the question
it's a it's a topical one we have at
various points during the course of the
crisis in Syria weighed the merits and
risks of various forms of zones as we
shorthand and no-fly zones safe zones on
the ground where civilians could be
protected I think that's what you mean
and then we've also looked at something
that we've termed a buffer zone which is
not necessarily a safe zone with
protection for civilians on the ground
but some zone meant to be a bulwark so
that people and weapons and other
malicious flows of goods and the light
can't continue to occur in all honesty
these are options that that we continue
to examine we have not
ruled out any of them in a formal or
permanent way but we've looked at them
very very closely including again very
recently and they are fraught with real
challenges and difficulties they are
incredibly resource intensive to secure
so take your model of let me call it a
safe zone on let's say the northern or
southern border within Syria either a
budding turkey or a budding Jordan where
it see erratically civilians might be
protected to to enforce a safe zone
effectively you not only need planes in
the air and the planes in the air are
complicated because the threat that most
of the the most proximate danger to
civilians is in fact not fixed-wing
aircraft it's helicopters dropping
barrel bombs that are harder to deal
with in the context of an aircraft and
then it's on the ground where you need
literally tens of thousands of troops to
hold and clear that territory where
those troops would come from whether
weighing our interests you would use our
air power and our forces to protect
folks on the ground and clearing out
territory or whether you would use them
to go after Israel because they are not
the same mission is one of the tricky
questions that policymakers have to
weigh a trade-off where if we were to
employ additional resources would they
best be utilized a humanitarian mission
which is the one you're describing is
not it's not the same as the
counter-isil mission in the current
context there may be a point when they
allied but they don't at the moment and
then you you have the question of to
what extent is that actually improved
conditions on the ground
the major border crossings are open to
humanitarian aid the aid is flowing
so particularly into the areas near the
border that we're talking about so the
incremental benefit to civilians are
actual humanitarian experts do not think
is is very significant and there's a
real question as to whether the
establishment of these zones would draw
people back in or actually cause them to
flee for fear that they're going to be
trapped in these zones where they'd
rather have freedom of movement
internally or externally so there
there's a huge number of complexities
associated with this which is not to say
these are options that are off the table
but we are digging into them very deeply
and they are not as simple and obvious
solutions is you might hear if by
turning on you know CNN and listening to
to what the pundits are saying thank you
over here I sorry I have laryngitis I
didn't want to pass up this opportunity
to ask your question it may be for both
of you one is as a woman of color you're
constantly in international settings
where you are maybe the only woman in
the room
or the only African American or well not
always but often during how you handle
yourself in those situations where you
might find sexism or some type of
discrimination against you because of
who you are and the other part of my
question is I teach at an inner-city
high school here in New Haven at Hill
House and it may be more towards you
choice what do you think we can do at
the local level to help our kids for to
experience things like this to expose
them to international because they think
very small they think very locally and
to get them to think more outside of New
Haven or their particular situations and
contribute like you were talking about
at the end about there are so many
resources that we don't have
for whatever reason that America might
be losing out on the potential that we
have and who knows you know maybe the
person who has a cure for cancer is a
high school student in Hill House but
they may not have the same opportunities
hideout perhaps so if you could address
that and this okay
did you all hear the question
so that one was directed to me and one
was directed to Johnny the one directed
to me was I hope I don't do it miss
justice but essentially as an
african-american woman finding herself
in various international settings how do
I deal with some being the only one or
being certainly one a few and have I
faced you know discrimination and and
delight and I I think the answer is you
know obviously there there some
circumstances where I may be the only
woman in the room or the only person of
color but I'm representing the United
States of America and I have found that
when when I show up in whatever role I'm
in even when I was in far more junior
roles as a representative the United
States of America people primarily dealt
with me on that basis and I can't
pretend that there have been occasions
when you know I people have made flipped
comments or you know we've been somewhat
condescending but for the most part they
don't have the the space or the ability
to to do that or to dwell on it because
they know at the end of the day that
they have to deal for better or for
worse with whatever the United States
government is coming or saying or doing
and that's the basis on which I have
found that that I'm interacting on most
if not all occasions and so I to a great
extent have not found that to be an
impediment
far more of an impediment frankly but
still overridden by this fact that I was
representing the US government was when
I was 32 years old and the Assistant
Secretary of State for African affairs
and often the senior American official
going around representing the United
States and it was my youth rather than
my gender or my race that was most
noticed and still not something that at
the end of the day got in the way of my
doing my job I quickly say a relative to
Hill House sure you know it's the easy
answer is to to expose your students you
know to what's happening over here
Yale's and get them over here and
invited to things like this and so forth
I think that's part of it I'm sure we
can do more of that but I also think the
heart the tougher thing in the thing we
do more of is take the Yale over to them
it's you know and and and meet them
where they are you know I just just
coincidentally when I was a student here
I started a mash was my first exposure
to to kind of my first book in
excitement around mentoring and and and
the social sector actually started a
program over at Hill House high school
this is back in the 80s that was called
Young Men's Leadership Forum and we took
we brought a bunch of Yale students over
to to Hill house every week and we did
study skills and mentoring we did you
know a lot of work on the ground in the
classrooms of those students and just to
provide most of whom were teenage
fathers okay and we just met them where
they were and we you know we helped and
we built relationships and and we were
there you know in their house I think
that really made it over another thing
we did which is sort of out of that that
I think you could argue we maybe is is
the kind of thing we could do more of
but just as a fun entrepreneurial thing
you know for those who don't know at
least back then Hill House had a great
basketball tradition and invade would
when they would play Wilbur cross here
they would have more people
Payne Whitney Jim then we would have and
when we were flying he'll be a
basketball table and so so they thought
they were really good basketball so I
brought made out I was on the basketball
team here we went over to Hill House and
played it brought you know when we were
seniors played a game in their gym Yale
varsity basketball versus them and and
we had them introduced it speak to we
had speakers it was a fantastic sort of
community event and brought in and built
a lot of bridges things like that I mean
that's ways you know many many years ago
but just an example of things that we
can do more of and I'm sure we're doing
a lot of it much already that Peter
could speak to but figuring out ways to
bring the best of Yale to them in
addition to thinking about exposure
around them coming to us great who won
the game we kill them I don't either
actual witnesses yes we killed and the
yes there are so Tim Shriver who's you
know chairman Special Olympics was a
teacher over it will over and allows
then and and and he will attest he was
at my partner in building this
initiative with it that was very
accessible and and not only do we win
but are we wasn't me in this case but
one of our one of my teammates won the
dunk contest against those guys okay so
it was it was an eye-opening moment for
Hill House news yes over here please so
there's a little over a year left in
President Obama's term and I'm just
wondering looking back and even a little
bit forward is there such a thing as an
Obama doctrine anything resembling that
and if that's the case is there
something it's there a rice doctrine the
rights to action would have to be the
Obama doctrine for now for the next 15
months no you know we've really
refrained from from trying to distill
our approach into a doctrine I think if
you understand the way President Obama
approaches foreign policy and national
security
he is both principled and pragmatic and
he would reject as a matter of
intellectual point of view but also as a
matter of practice a one-size-fits-all
approach and so no we don't have a
doctrine what we what he would say and
what he deeply believes is that American
leadership is necessary and
indispensable that it can be and must be
a force for progress and for good but
there limits to what even the most
powerful nation on the planet can
accomplish for other people in their own
countries at the end of the day whether
it's political transformation or
economic growth or or even conflict
resolution there are vital contributions
that the United States and others in the
international community now typically
with American leadership can bring to
bear but at the end of the day there are
certain fundamentals that have to be
accomplished by and for the people of a
given country or a given region whether
it's fighting corruption cronyism
insisting on respect for human rights
the outside world can do a great deal to
call attention and demand certain
standards and performance but the end of
the day it will not last and it will not
be something that is fundamentally
enduring unless it is owned by the local
population and that's in many ways a
challenge we're facing in Syria and Iraq
it's the challenge we're facing in
Afghanistan it's a challenge that you
could argue is at the root of many of
the most difficult global problems that
we are wrestling with
Jackie hi thank you so much first of all
for sharing your insights with us up in
the room and we're figuring out what
actually to be and how and if we want
those to relate to our careers after
education so I was just wondering since
you hold degrees in different
disciplines if you could talk about the
values and interests that took you from
there to where you are today I wish I
could tell you that you know there was a
linear path between I was a history
major
Johnny studied at Latin American Studies
and then I went on and did international
relations I don't think so my piece of
advice if I have one is very simple and
that's to follow your passion do
whatever it is that motivates you and
excites you whether you think it's going
to get you a good job coming out of
college or not do what you find
fascinating and motivating and that's
what you're going to be good at and
that's what will take you to the next
and the next exciting thing I never
anticipated when I was an undergraduate
at Stanford that I would be in a career
in international affairs much less as
National Security Advisor or UN
Ambassador that was not I was going to
be a civil rights lawyer or you know a
community activist that's sort of how I
thought of my future and if I ever got a
home state that had voting rights as
opposed to the District of Columbia
where I grew up I thought maybe I might
run for public office and I've ended up
in a completely different place and but
the one thing I have done is follow my
heart in my head and do things that I
love to do and that's never led me
astray so that's what I would say one
thing I'll add Vettes while you're
following your passion work really hard
at this stage of your career to figure
out where what your genius gifts are
where you can be top ten top 20 percent
in your peer group what you do best and
what that translates into from a career
standpoint because it's great to be
focused on
that you love you know if you want to
you know I always share a story Pete
folks I want you know I want to be
recording artists but you better be able
to sing right if you can't thing I don't
care how passion you are about music I
think I'm making money doing that right
so focus on you know that combined with
the people who get the farthest people
who realize their potential we've found
have they they combine this that sweet
spot that Lane which is what you're
passionate about and what you're you
know where your genius gifts are and
because what you need to focus on at
this stage early on is being a high
performer and if you're a high procure
more likely high performer if you're
focused on what your passion about but
you're most likely die for if you're
really good at what you're doing and
being high formable for position you
develop the relationships that you will
that will really catapult your career
that I think everyone here who's more
you know tenured there could speak to
about how important that is so I'm
afraid we're actually out of time so I'm
feel very badly for the beef you two
want your two lines though it's waited
so patiently
can we please give ambassador rice and
John rice another round
thank you
you
[Music]